you're okay you're staying glad to be
here
thanks for the invite uh listen i got
a king understanding for y'all
decorating for the holidays
he barely opens i don't mean decorating
i'm sorry it looks like it hurts
so i just recently got back from college
just graduated
and i'm back living with the parents
north pole state
and this is just what i got to deal with
i mean there's so many decorations
there's decorations hiding decorations
oh this is just mom's house
so i'm just wondering guys
uh you can't understand it decorating
the inside of your home for the holidays
love you guys gang gang
buzz buzz
sound like an aging boxer dude that was
unbelievable that was unbelievable that
he thought that he should have that
whole video played
out of things but i couldn't stop
watching because i was like am i going
to see his tongue or not
i don't think he has a tongue that guy i
think he's hiding the fact he didn't
have a tongue
look at him see if he has a tongue he's
a shark right yeah right
look at this i've never seen a shark
tongue there's no there's no shark
tongue my boy my cannon mike peter i
think we're talking about that they're
like they don't have tongues it's just a
hole
yeah why do they need a tongue it tastes
good yeah right if it's there
no no time no no it would be cool if our
tongues were flavored though wouldn't it
flavored tongues get you a little
barbecued tongue little barbecue time i
just have it all day where you playing
ball so you could take that
barbecue ball people like damn what you
eating you know
like oh just having a little bit of
myself
uh that grain did your girl did your
fiance decorate the
apartment yeah yeah yeah we did a little
christmas tree action
this shit's dope chicks [ __ ] if you got
kids you definitely need to do it oh
yeah
yeah look i'm about the christmas spirit
man me too let's get into it
it doesn't look like it today i know
we're doing a [ __ ] christmas episode
but like let's go
no you didn't bring any fashion for us
even though we've watched a million
stories about it i was gonna send you
guys passion i had it all like printed
and everything and then i remember i
asked you for your uh
the address i was like where can i send
some stuff yeah what happened bro a
global pandemic
i literally have it at the studio like
putting these like cool uh
plastic containers yeah it's [ __ ] up
pandemic kit pandemic kit
and then what you just been selling it
to everybody else yeah because my thick
voice
[Laughter]
buy a shirt you
what's cheap on why does everybody need
free shirts you're right bro come on
all right did you see that did you
decorate the place in nashville
no no uh decorated the studio we just
had santa claus on actually nick you
want to pull up that up real quick yes
sir dude we had the real santa
cane wow and he was dude from a mall in
nashville or what he works at a smoothie
king four days a week
but he is so talented this is a sad
story
wait till you see this man yeah he's
talented this man is on guys before you
play this i don't
trust anybody who wants to play santa
claus in the mall this is also said this
next level podcasting because like we're
podcasting
watching oh damn
wow
[Laughter]
make a dance
[Laughter]
can we make the leah jokes about a guy
who has kids sit on his lap
you guys are [ __ ] up buy some fashion
you freaks
buy some [ __ ] fashion yeah
but dude this is what it feels like when
you meet him that's the look you have on
your face and that's him bro look how
big he is
he's almost seven feet tall and he works
at a smoothie king he works outside of
one
[Laughter]
oh he doesn't work force me hitting on
man he's a hired man
he's a higher goal did he come through
with the reindeer uh no he's but he said
that they have some reindeer that are on
jv he went dude
bro he's saying there's no doubt that
santa was he fifty dollars an hour some
[ __ ] uh
i think he was about 300 for the visit
oh damn santa
[Music]
is